this car vr dinghy
it's called the yaris
yes this is not a brand integration
is this
so this shoots kind of like the other
shoe right so can you kind of just walk
me through how it's going to go action
all right cool yo what up this is the
bts camera what's up
all right so how are we shooting this
well we're shooting it top down with a
gopro taking multiple multiple frames
while we do it how are we doing that how
do you get a gopro high enough above you
so that you can do these kind of shots
well it's pretty simple actually niko
and carmichael put together a pvc rig
they went and bought i think i believe
that's
inch and a quarter
pvc piping
with some links and joints in there and
they marked it all so you can be easily
taken apart and put back together
basically just makes a big frame and you
put the gopro in the middle
we just get some bullets
yeah it sounds like
bam
[Music]
ric flair baby
[Music]
so uh just went through all that trouble
to cut a hole and you'll notice
here's the hole
and here's where it needs to be
sometimes in life you can't go running
off to your mommy and daddy every time
you got a [ __ ] problem sometimes you
got to bust out a cheap chinese-made
knife and just cut into something this
is america
don't try this at home
you would be just getting back right now
all right niko
[Music]
where's that gopro
[Music]
this
all right
hey guys so some things that we learned
after day number three always do
choreography before you do stop motion
number two
generally you can't shoot during the
mid-afternoon because uh
shadows
completely ruin your frame so consider
the morning and the afternoon or
days where you know it's going to be
cloudy number three to do about eight
seconds
of stop-motion footage takes about 45
minutes
bill nye let's sign this guy
day number four
coming out to the park trying to get
some pictures of us rolling around on
the ground like a bunch of idiots this
is my life
so we went to nab this year as you might
recall small hd actually gave us one of
their monitors before they were even out
and we've actually been using it on this
camera and it's really cool because
right now i have it running expanded
focus view so i can be looking at my red
monitor as my general framing and i can
look over at my small hd monitor for
high res focus pulling what's up guys so
for stop motion kung fu karate stop
motion karate sorry i always get the two
confu confused
we had a little bit of an interesting
challenge if you guys remember in
stop-motion parkour you can kind of see
the camera wiggling because we filmed
with a gopro on top of a big pvc rig and
for that i basically just ran the shots
through warp stabilizer it wasn't
perfect but it did the job well enough
but the story is a little bit different
for this video jake and alex fall down
they start fighting the camera is
basically supposed to be locked off i
ran through warp stabilizer and it did
nothing so i was like okay cool
maybe mocha can fix it nope
maybe i can just regular point track it
nope
so i came up with a new solution where
basically you would do a motion track
and reproject the image from the
position of the camera onto the inside
of the sphere and that basically gave
you a stabilized shot sounds confusing
it sounds kind of crazy just bear with
me it'll make sense once you watch this
okay so so here i have a shot from the
piece it's the second uh little fight
sequence here and the camera moves
laterally over the ground until it
settles here by the rocks and they
continue fighting it's technically
rocking back and forth at the top where
the pvc rig is so in order to fix this i
needed to motion track the gopro i
needed to then bring that back into
after effects and effectively create a
old classic film projector where it
projects the image from that motion
track camera back onto the ground let me
show you how this works so here's the
shot at full speed you see how it's all
wiggly and i've undistorted the gopro
footage using optics compensation so i
take this shot and i bring it into boozu
and i just do a simple feature track and
then camera solve we actually have a
great booster tutorial that ren helped
us make if you guys want to see a little
bit more about how to track with buju
did a feature track which tracked all
the points in the image and then i did a
camera solve which then went on and
basically reconstructed where the camera
was in 3d space works great so then what
i do is i export the camera back into
after effects and we can see here a
couple of points i exported from buju
and we see they're tracking just fine to
the scene so now i'm going to do a handy
little trick generally known as
projection mapping or camera mapping red
actually has a great tutorial that he
did on how to do this so you have your
camera and you put a light right exactly
on the camera you can actually hold
shift and pick whip the light to the
camera from boujou and it'll put the
light exactly on the camera and parent
it to the camera and then i take the
footage layer and i duplicate it i make
it 3d i move it so it's just slightly
off the front of the camera and i shrink
it down so it's actually acting just
like a piece of film would in a camera
projector so now what i need to do is i
need to create a plane at the distance
of those points basically the ground
plane i then need to project the image
back onto that ground plane so here's
how i go about doing that in after
effects so i'm going to create a solid
and put line it up with that ground
plane you can go to layer new solid turn
that on i've already lined it up right
now there's not much to look at if i
turn off my background video layer
you're just gonna see a bunch of white
and a bunch of points and that's it so
now i need to project the image from the
camera so i named the camera coming out
of boujou the projector to make it
project next thing i will need to do is
duplicate my video layer and make it 3d
and then you move it exactly to the
camera and to do that i'll just hold
shift click on the pick whip and then go
over and select the projector so now the
footage plane has been lined up exactly
to the center of the camera right here
now it's obviously very big and if you
imagine film being going through
projector the film's actually really
small and just in front of the camera so
i'm going to do just that i'm going to
move the image just a little bit in
front of the camera so maybe one percent
size yeah a little small two percent
that'll do basically you wanted it to be
exactly lined up with the edges of your
frame oh and work on frame one next
thing you need to do is create a light
so you imagine a film projector you have
a light that is shining through that
film and casting a shadow onto a cinema
background cinema backing cinema drop
screen cinema screen layer new light
needs cast shadows that's technically
what happens when you shine light
through projector now this light once
again you move it to be exactly where
the camera is to turn that camera into
projector so hold shift click on the
pick whip and let go on projector so not
only doesn't move the light to be
exactly lined up with the camera we look
right here it also makes the light stick
to the camera so as the camera moves
through 3d space the light will stick
right with it projecting from the camera
so now here's where things get a little
fancy so i needed to tell after effects
this light needs to catch shadows i need
to tell after effects the white solid
that i have on my ground plane is only
going to receive shadows and i need to
tell after effects that that video layer
that i have scooted just in front of the
camera basically acting as our film that
we're going to project through and you
tell it that that is going to only cast
shadows and that's going to pass 100 of
the light through it here's my little
frame of film in front of the camera in
front of the light right here hit the
little drop down here go to material
options cast shadows set to only light
transmission 100 except lights can be
turned off so it's only catching shadows
and it's passing through 100 of the
light boom next up are white solid for
our settings for that we're going to go
down to our material options go to cache
shadows turn that off we only need it to
accept shadows and then our light of
course needs to have shadows turned on
so this is basically it here we have our
camera here we have our light and here
we have our little piece of the video
that's going to be projecting onto the
background down here on the ground we
have a white solid boom so now if we
watch this hopefully you can see how
this is working we see our 3d tracked
camera reprojecting the image that we
filmed with that camera onto a ground
plane that is lined up with the ground
plane that we 3d tracked you effectively
get a stabilized image it's all a little
crazy it's all a little weird it's a
little hard to describe but hopefully
with the visual of seeing how this
functions you can kind of wrap your head
around the concept anyways guys this is
how you 3d track a camera reproject the
footage in after effects and get rock
solid stabilizations using this
technique i hope you find it useful i
also want to give a big shout out to our
patrons who helped make this video
possible if you're not a patron you're
missing out on some cool tutorials for
example we're doing an interactive
tutorial on how to do this kind of
stabilization work
i will be answering questions and going
more in depth in the technique and how
it can be used in a lot of different
situations if you're watching this it's
already too late the video pledges have
already gone out but sign up for the
next one we do a lot of interesting
lessons and a lot of cool tutorials and
we give away a lot of files as well so
check it out i had to give up nicotine
this is my first day
i'm a little on edge